porque tenemos al vector y al vector w
ambos tienen sus componentes xy james su
componente x su componente james y son
vectores en dos dimensiones y a los dos
los gráfica mos justo aquí si te das
cuenta el vector uno tiene como
componente x2 y como componente 10 menos
uno
así que si ponemos el punto inicial de
este vector
en el origen y caminamos 2 a la derecha
y uno hacia abajo llegamos al punto
final o a la cabeza del vector 12 coma
menos 1 justo aquí y para el vector w
bueno este tiene como componentes menos
5 5
es decir que si ponemos al punto inicial
del vector w en el origen y caminamos 5
a la izquierda en x y después subimos 5
unidades
llegamos al punto menos 5.5 su
componente x es menos 5 y su componente
de 5 bien ya que tenemos estos dos
vectores yo lo que quiero es encontrar y
evaluar lo que resulta de 3
es el vector o más un quinto del vector
w y te invito a que pause el vídeo e
intentes en resolverlo por ti mismo
bueno tres y un quinto son escalares
ellos van a escalar estos vectores y
veremos cómo pasa esto y después lo
graficar hemos entonces vamos a escalar
al vector uno por tres lo vamos a
aumentar por tres y vamos a multiplicar
al vector w por un quinto vamos a
reducir este vector w
al escalarlo por un quinto y después
sumaremos los vectores resultantes
entonces manos a la obra cuando
escalamos al vector por tres podemos ver
esto como tres que multiplican al vector
uno pero el vector
tiene como componentes dos coma menos
uno
o bien podemos escribirlo de la
siguiente manera podemos escribir aquí
un paréntesis aquí uno dos aquí un -1 y
bueno por acá cierro el paréntesis y
entonces me va a quedar 3 que multiplica
a mi primera componente a mi componente
x 3 que multiplica a 2 y 3 que va a
multiplicar a mi segunda componente a mi
componente y así que 3 que multiplica a
menos 1 y por supuesto nuestro vector
resultante me va a quedar como tres
veces la componente x lo cual va a ser 6
3 por 12 6 y después 3 por menos 1 lo
cual es menos 3 entonces mi vector
resultante tiene como componente x 6 y
como componente y menos 3
así que grafique mosley y si yo me tomo
en esta gráfica que tengo aquí a este
vector que va a ser tres veces y voy a
tener una componente x de 6 por lo tanto
me tengo que mover 6 unidades a la
derecha
a 2 3 4 5 6 y después tengo que bajar 3
unidades en el eje y así que si bajo una
dos tres unidades más o menos voy a
estar como por más o menos voy a estar
como por aquí aquí lo tienes este es mi
vector tres veces uno y observa como mi
componente x me dice que nos movamos 1 2
3 4 5 6 unidades a la derecha estamos
justo aquí y mi componente me dice que
me mueva 123 unidades hacia abajo porque
es menos 3 así que voy a llegar justo
aquí en la historia y ahora observa que
en este vector tiene la misma dirección
que el vector un solo que tiene tres
veces su magnitud es decir que si por
aquí tenemos
por aquí estará dos veces y bueno por
acá tendremos tres veces
y hasta ahorita solamente nos hemos
fijado en
a parte de aquí es nuestra primera parte
después tenemos más un quinto del vector
w así que vamos a ponerlo más
un quinto del vector w
vector w lo voy a escribir con sus
componentes el vector w
es el vector menos 5,5
así que si ahora hacemos algo parecido
nos va a quedar de la siguiente manera
más y ahora voy a abrir un paréntesis
aquí voy a poner aquí la componente x
menos 5 una coma
bill por acá mi componente y justo así y
ahora voy a multiplicar cada una de las
componentes por un quinto así que la
componente x la voy a multiplicar por un
quinto y voy a hacer lo mismo con la
componente y la componente y la voy a
multiplicar por un quinto bien pues
vamos a hacerlo
a esto le voy a sumar y me queda un
quinto por menos 5 es menos 1 y después
tengo un quinto por 5 lo cual es uno de
lujo entonces este vector un quinto w va
a ser este vector w pero reducido en un
quinto menos 1 1 aquí tenemos el punto
final
el vector se va a ver justo así observa
que es el mismo vector w
pero solo nos estamos tomando una quinta
parte de él tiene la misma dirección
pero la magnitud se redujo en una quinta
parte ahora queremos sumar estos dos
vectores entonces los sumamos solamente
viendo sus componentes que voy a obtener
bueno pues esto va a ser igual a tomarme
y déjame agarrar un nuevo color que no
hayamos usado este de aquí
este vector resultante me va a quedar en
la componente x la suma de 6 con menos 1
déjame ponerlo voy a sumar 6 más bueno
menos 1 más menos 1 y en la componente
que me va a quedar menos 3 menos 3 ya
esto le voy a sumar
les voy a sumar
y ahora si nuestro vector resultante va
a tener como componentes bueno como
componente x va a ser 6 menos 1 lo cual
es 5 y como componente lleva a ser menos
tres más uno lo cual es menos 2 así que
estas son las componentes de mi vector
resultante bien pues ahora vamos a ver
qué nos queda aquí en la gráfica si
empezamos con este vector que era tres
veces y el cual ya tenemos aquí este es
tres veces y ya esto le sumamos el
vector un quinto de w y usamos el método
de unir la cabeza con la cola entonces
que me va a quedar
bueno pues empiezo justo aquí en mi
punto final del vector tres veces y le
voy a poner el punto inicial de mi
vector un quinto de w
y tengo que caminar una unidad hacia la
izquierda y una unidad hacia arriba
entonces voy a llegar justo a este otro
punto final así que si ahora lo uno me
va a quedar más o menos así aquí voy a
tener al vector
quinto de w va en esta dirección y ojo
date cuenta que estoy uniendo el punto
final del vector tres veces uno con el
punto inicial el vector un quinto de w y
ahora si quiero ver mi vector resultante
este lo voy a obtener poniendo su punto
inicial en el origen y su punto final en
donde llegó este vector es decir en la
cabeza del segundo vector y entonces
obtenemos un vector que se ve justo así
este vector tiene como componentes 5,22
y aquí lo puedes ver su componente x 5 1
2 3 4 5 y bajamos 2 unidades en 10 1 2 y
llegamos justo aquí así que ya está nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo